la famille ça représente peut-être
quelque chose dans laquelle on aime bien
sentir de temps en temps mais pas trop
sinon pourquoi pas trop pas trop parce
que notre âge on commence à vouloir être
un peu indépendant puis en avoir un peu
assez quoi est-ce que ce bateau quelque
chose d'important
oh oui c'est important parce que on a
quand même un peu de reconnaissance si
on peut dire un peu beaucoup mais
la famille
on peut considérer ça surtout comme un
clown sort de cellules plus ou moins
fermé une bonne famille ça va reposer
sur une confiance mutuelle entre toutes
les personnes qui la composent
la famille doit être à mon avis un blog
est ce que vous aimeriez ressembler à
votre père votre mère voilà les deux
d'accord pas de dire que ça doit être
une cellule fermait doit pas du tout
être fermé à mon avis elle dort c'est
pas parce que on est des gens ont été
remis fermé je suis mon ventre à ça
parce que on vit donc dans un bel
appartement on vit on mange avec des
mêmes gens et tout que qu'on doit voir
qu'on doit au fond d'avoir des rapports
- avec d'autres personnes qui
constituent ne compose pas la famille
moi je sais que si on s'entend pas du
tout avec nos parents on travaille plus
en classe on rentre tard et on se
dispute encore on travaille plus quoi on
essaie de chercher refuge ailleurs
et tout compte fait ça nous retombe
dessus à chaque fois quoi parce que je
rêve chose est primordiale et les
parents doivent essayer de se mettre à
la portée des enfants
enfin pour ça se mettre à genoux et
avoir les mêmes opinions enfin qu'il ait
une discussion réelle s'est voulu sans
pour cela être collé tout le temps la
famille dit quoi
question quelles sont les qualités que
réclame le fait d'être parent à votre
avis
qualité
je pense que pour les parents la qualité
essentielle est certainement la
compréhension des des enfants doivent se
mettre plutôt au niveau des enfants est
évidemment certainement faire quelques
sacrifices
nous on doit les faire aussi ce que le
fossé génération existe vraiment entre
les parents oui non c'est à dire que je
crois qu'il faut c'est des générations
on le ressent beaucoup moi quand on est
avec nos parents et quand on est avec
une personne qu'on connaît pas je sais
pas je crois que ça s'explique sur tout
ce qu'on a toujours des pieds avec nos
parents on a l'impression que sont nos
frères un peu faim leur dauphin c'est sa
foi qu'ils ont exactement les marches
que nous enfin moi je ne sais pas je vis
avec maintenant j'ai l'impression
qu'elle est même âge que moi qui
pourrait prendre son père ou sa mère
comme modèle d'une vie future personne
on veut ressembler à quelqu'un non pas
parce que les nous faire ou notre mère
parce que il est comme ça au comme ça
moi je sais pas quand je vois des gens
pour mieux mes parents personnellement
que je travaille avec mes parents soient
comme ça plutôt comme ça si vous voulez
pas parce que si mes parents
heureusement c'est ce que vous permettez
de critiquer vos parents moi je peux
peut-être les critiquer mais pas les
seuls non mais vous avoir
non je n'ai pas le droit mais pas le
droit non titre que moi je ne veux pas
les critiquer il voulait les critiques
et un moment ou un autre
qu'est ce que vous auriez le repos à
leur reprocher
cage ils ont au bord m'a moins trente
cinq ans six ans mon père 1 38 ans et
mon beau-père 40 ans mais vous les
critiquez pas parce que ce sont des
parents et c'est une institution que
locale à laquelle on doit pas toucher
non parce que je ne suis pas je ne pense
pas que moi de 16 ans puissent critiquer
quelqu'un qui a vécu parce qu important
alors nicole je connais tous d'accord ça
va ce qu'on a 16 ans on étudie aussi
quand même tu tu vois tu regardes tu
parles tu tu existes est ce que tu
voudrais voir par exemple
bon camarade et puis tu lioret est ce
que je suis pas d'accord avec mes
parents vraiment ils ont pas fait ce
qu'ils auraient dû faire à ce que tu le
froid ce qui reste à faire mais je ne
critique pas heureusement
comment envisagez vous votre propre
famille plus tard alors très fermé
samedi sans vraiment un cercle fermé
est ce qu'ils vont dire à vos enfants la
même éducation qu'on lui a donnée à vous
peut-être pas un peu plus large
oui mais toujours c'est un soutien ce
que la pluie ça doit être très unie et
chaque membre de la famille toi tout
seul vers des jours
pour un enfant c'est très important
quand la famille n'est pas revenu quand
il manque quelqu'un je crois que tu
coches de déséquilibre de l'enfant ça ne
sert à nos études et puis quand on a
besoin d'eux quand on a besoin de
résoudre un problème quand on a quand on
a eu par exemple une mauvaise note qu on
est découragé quand même bon de le sang
se faire remonter le moral de trouver du
plaisir accueillant comme turquie
retrouver les mêmes habitudes les mêmes
pour les chauffeurs car pour moi c'est
un lieu de refuge et de protection est
ce que le dialogue existe donc à fermer
par exemple ça si oui qu'est ce que vous
vous dites
par exemple dans mon travail quand je ne
comprend pas quelque chose et que mes
parents ne savent pas rom à cette
question au lendemain on un peu plus
tard au mois je sais pas moi avec mes
parents je pars les copains et copines
du travail parce qu'ils peuvent m'aider
et puis parce qu'ils doutent chose qua
non la vie pour monsieur angoissant car
avec un échange entre eux vers toi oui
parce que je n'ai pas entre non
confiance c'est sèche trouve surtout qui
compte parce que si on n'est pas en
confiance avait des parents bas je pense
qu'on arrivera grand chose j'ai capable
de parler de n'importe quoi ton parent a
tempéré what am r oui de tous
[Musique]
je me sens bien que parent je peins
contracté quoi quand je leur parle
quel sort attend l'avis des raisons les
faca sont chez toi les raisons les plus
fréquents de disputer va à l'école
parce que moi quand je rentre de l'école
je vous je fais des bruyants du travail
il y en a des fois ils ont fait beaucoup
de trajets en métro bondé bruit alors
quand je fais un peu trop au goût et à
la maison fois je me fais que ça y est
je crois qu'on s'en soucie que nous
parents s'intéressent à nous qu'ils
veulent faire quelque chose de nous et
qui qui s'occupe de nous qui pensent à
nous et qu'ils essayent de nous faire
arriver à quelque chose de nous préparer
à la future et d'où ils essaient de nous
et des essais quelles sont les qualités
de départ en général je crois que ma
mère était une bonne mère de famille
et puis mon père il nous entraîne à
arette diplomate dans dans vos réponses
miles est ce que tu te permets de
critiquer tu es vraiment non je crois
que inoubou il va nous élever ils font
tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour nous et puis
non je vois pas pourquoi on les critique
rennes
[Musique]
la preuve de la même idée n'a pas trop
sévère mais trop lâches pourquoi trop
large plus tôt
mais ce qui t'arrive de leur faire de
réflexion jamais maintenant c'est bon il
dit arrête de parler de tes parents avec
des camarades
puis c'est l'heure des bilans tissu
imbibé série bon moi aussi mais pas si
j'en parle quand j'en parle avec nos
camarades c'est cela la manière dont un
de nos élèves
si ça en bien ou en mal vous avez des
discussions sur la façon dont les
parents d'élèves quelquefois ils vous
confronter les différents paliers
télécommande on bosse bien
il suffit de bien de moi ils ont de
l'affection comment tu envisages
marylène ta famille plus tard le plus
juste possible de des mémés enfants j'en
ai essayé de les rendre heureux de ne
pas leur côté de la peine
je voudrais pas les embêter pour leur
dire leur dire faites 6 7 face à tout ça
je voudrais que et qu ils ne comprennent
vite qui voudrait pas que ce soit une
obligation je voudrais qu'ils soient
qu'ils nous respectent
attali quel est ton avis là dessus moi
j'essaierai de bien de couper et puis à
quoi tu auras des enfants
faire c'est leur donnez moi ce que j'ai
eus parce que je trouve que moi je le
trouve quasi très heureuse comme je suis
alors si je pouvais arriver à donner
seul moi ce que j'ai eu à mes enfants
bien d'après ce que je ressens je crois
qu'ils seront comme moi aussi mais à
temps d'agir heureux ça veut dire quoi
vient d'abord être heureuse dans à
plusieurs moments ce soir encore plaidé
quand on a des parents 13 unités
c'est une chose fondamentale
[Musique]